are you thinking what i think you're
thinking i'm thinking it what are we
thinking thinking we're taking it too
the hotly anticipated sequel to thor
ragnarok thor love and thunder made fans
bang their proverbial hammers with
excitement here's a looky-loo to see all
the chaos and fun that surrounded the
making of the marvel flick
number one
that's gotta hurt while it's no secret
that any actor called upon to take a
marvel movie leading role is going to
have to get into some kind of
over-the-top muscular shape all that
weightlifting can come at a cost chris
hemsworth as thor learned the hard way
by wrecking his back mid-thor love and
thunder while the exact injury and
circumstances surrounding it are still
shrouded in mystery hemsworth had to
injure cortisol injections to keep
holding up that hammer
number 2
ouch adapting a beloved comic book hero
onto the big screen is no small feat
and unfortunately sometimes characters
get the boot e tree played by peter
dinklage sadly didn't make the cut this
time
however christian bale who plays the
main villain gore the godbutcher said he
treasured his time on set with dinklage
the other character who the editor of
thor had to say
sorry not sorry to was the grandmaster
played by everyone's favorite rambling
actor jeff goldblum it's safe to say
that we demand a buddy comedy spin-off
featuring dinklage and goldblum thank
you
number three
it's getting spicy now the moment that
all fan fiction writers and weirdos were
asking for finally made an appearance in
thor love and thunder thor's nude
physique and when nudity is called for
in a feature film it tends to be dealt
tenderly and privately according to
director taiko ititi there were over 350
people on set that day most of whom had
never spent one day on the set before or
after the entire shoot here's hoping
chris wasn't too cold that day number
four
can't stop won't stop director taika ytt
may have won an academy award for
writing his movie jojo rabbit but his
real skill is making the actors do the
make-em-ups showcased in his movie what
we do in the shadows his flair for
improv is unmatched and great news is
his directing style allowed actors like
chris hemsworth to improvise some
hilarious moments that fans will love
hemsworth explained it's free form
there's a lot of improvisation that's
just an unrivaled passion there was an
enthusiasm that was infectious among
everybody
number five
get ready to dance marvel movies have
found a way to impact all levels of the
entertainment industry especially the
music world with soundtracks like
guardians of the galaxy making gen z
kids groove to the 70s hits director
taika ytti hopes to hit the same notes
in his choice of 80s classics waititi
said he spent his youth obsessed with
bands like guns n roses and metallica
and is so thrilled they were able to
make it into thor love and thunder
because nothing says superhero quite
like a seven minute slash guitar solo
number six
was gore the god but you're going to be
the lord of the dance while many rumors
have come out of thor love and thunder
one that fans were desperate to be true
was christian balesville and gore the
god butcher having a full dance scene to
a kate bush song and while the scene was
never actually filmed it was according
to bale vividly discussed but some
dreams never do make it to the big
screen and watching a grotesque bale
dance to babushka can only live in our
heads
number seven
get ready for mighty thor
after years of mostly male superheroes
thor love and thunder finally is
allowing the girl character to become
three-dimensional and cause all the
drama natalie portman who plays jane
foster steps into thor's very large
shoes and gets to strut her stuff as a
god and hero portman elaborated on this
exciting opportunity saying getting this
opportunity was such an incredible way
to explore a female superhero that could
be quite vulnerable and weak find
strength in that and be more like a
human i could relate to personally thank
goodness her costume wasn't all pink
number eight
and the chaos continues no matter how
much chaos and excitement there already
is behind the scenes sometimes it's nice
to have family around so for all you
cameo heads keep your eyes open for
chris hemsworth's real-life wife and
children to make an appearance tbh on a
movie like this the more chaos the
better so the kids brought it number
nine
most movies need a big star to get off
the ground however when you have a
built-in fan base like a marvel
franchise that may not always be the
case but this time chris hemsworth made
this fourth thor movie happen because of
how damn hilarious he is according to
ytt chris showed off his comedic chops
in avengers age of ultron and made the
studios decide that yeah they do want to
see a comedy version of thor and
thankfully fans do too number 10
what's that christian bale is a
sought-after actor with both box office
and critical success so choosing him to
play the villain gore the godbutcher was
a no-brainer and while bale is known to
transform himself both through his
acting and his literal body also known
as how extremely thin he got in the
machinist he couldn't go the extra mile
body wise this time if fans recall gore
is a big hulky dude and in thor love and
thunder he's definitely leaned out this
was due to bale coming off of another
project where he needed to be thinner
maybe a first of hollywood not wanting
someone to be thinner for a role number
11.
we'd pass on this ever since gwyneth
group paltrow introduced the world to
the wim hof method hollywood has been
dipping their toes into ice baths and
while this is a long practice tradition
by all top grade athletes the cast of
thor gave it a go as well having the
actors reinvigorate their tense muscles
with an ice bath is literally what the
doctor ordered number 12.
we gotta talk about the goats in thor
love and thunder goats play a prominent
role um fun and while these ones were
all cgi the actors had to stare and
react at something for acting's sake so
they brought in the goat sculptures
no word on how realistic they were but
here's hoping they look as ridiculous as
they must have felt to act against a
sculpture number 13. the original cut of
thor love and thunder was just over four
hours according to hemsworth who called
it an assembly of madness fans should be
relieved that the theatrical version is
much much shorter however it would have
been pretty cool to see a 20-minute
scene of thor's morning routine
number 14.
romance is in the air if upon watching
thor love and thunder you can't help but
think you've seen certain images in
print form ever so slightly concealed on
your mom's nightstand you're right for
having this feeling director taika ytt
based his cinematography choices on the
harlequin romance novel aesthetic based
on publishing house mills and boone
moments in the movie and right down to
the poster why tt wanted the feeling of
flowing hair beauties and billowy shirts
one can only find in a drugstore book
section fingers crossed for a fabio
cameo someday number 15.
who would have thought marvel movies
tend to steer clear from any sort of
romantic storyline as if it were
kryptonite itself oops wrong comic book
franchise but thor love and thunder
leans right into the romance in fact
categorizing itself as a romantic comedy
director taika waititi even said he was
inspired by the rom-com an officer and a
gentleman
well then if it's color we need
let's bring the rainbow
hope you had fun walking through the
chaos and madness that was the
behind-the-scenes antics of thor love
and thunder which behind the scene
tidbit tickled your fancy like comment
and subscribe to the things for all the
thor you can hammer we mean handle